Off.
En 1917, Einstein comprit que ses équations
de la relativité générale prédisaient
une fin des temps.
Il ne pouvait pas l’accepter.
Il s’empressa alors de réexaminer sa théorie,
et la modifia.
Cette modification fut, en ses propres termes,
la plus grosse bêtise de sa vie.
Mais…
était-ce vraiment une bêtise ? J’y reviendrai
dans une minute.
Pour commencer, laissez-moi vous expliquer
ce qui a poussé Einstein à modifier ses
équations.
Off.
En supposant l’espace homogène, la matière
partout dans l’univers contribue à courber
positivement tout l’espace-temps qui la
contient.
Et ça, ça veut dire que les trajectoires
de la matière ne peuvent pas rester indéfiniment
parallèles.
Intuitivement, elles devraient finir par tous
se concentrer en un point, annonçant ainsi
une fin spectaculaire de notre espace-temps,
que l’on appelle parfois le Big Crunch.
Einstein ne pouvait pas l’accepter.
Il rejetait la possibilité d’une fin du
monde.
Il pensait que l’univers était statique,
éternel.
Off.
Du coup, au lieu de faire confiance à sa
toute nouvelle théorie de l’espace-temps,
Einstein lui tordit le coup en ajoutant un
terme de courbure négative, qu’il appela
la constante cosmologique.
Et ça, c’est déjà assez étrange.
Surtout venant d’Einstein.
Mais il y a pire.
Off.
En 1922, Alexander Friedmann soumit un article
à un journal à comité de lecture, avec
une solution aux équations originelles de
la relativité générale.
Friedmann supposa que l’univers était homogène
et isotrope à grandes échelles, mais qu’il
n’était pas statique.
La taille de l’univers avait ainsi une dynamique
à travers le temps, que l’on appelle le
facteur d’échelle.
Après de longs calculs savants, Friedmann
trouva les équations qui déterminent la
destinée de l’univers.
Off.
La prédiction de Friedmann dépendait de
la courbure $k$ de l’espace supposé homogène.
Cet espace pouvait être sphérique, comme
celui de l’épisode 11, plat comme dans
l’épisode 7, ou hyperbolique comme dans
l’épisode 12.
Dans tous les cas, Friedmann prédisit que
l’univers courait à sa perte, et que celle-ci
pouvait être un Big Crunch si l’espace
était sphérique, ou une expansion ralentie
mais infinie dans les autres cas, que l’on
appelle le Big Chill.
Off.
Quoiqu’il en soit, en tant que membre du
comité de lecture, Einstein fut extrêmement
critique.
Il rejeta l’article de Friedmann, en affirmant
que son contenu était erroné.
Il aura fallu près d’un an et de nombreuses
lettres pour qu’Einstein se rende compte
que ses critiques n’étaient pas fondées.
Einstein finit par rétracter ses critiques,
s’excuser, et reconnaître publiquement
la validité mathématique des solutions de
Friedmann.
Toutefois, ses notes privées montrent qu’il
n’en reconnaissait pas la validité physique…
La position de Friedmann est tout aussi surprenante.
Friedmann affirma que l’intérêt de son
article résidait uniquement dans la quête
d’une compréhension mathématique des équations
d’Einstein, et que ses solutions n’avaient
absolument rien à voir avec notre univers
physique.
Oui, c’était un bon mathématicien.
Heureusement, vint ensuite l’abbé Lemaître.
Off.
La spécificité de Georges Lemaître était
d’être à la fois un prêtre et un physicien
de premier rang.
En 1927, en étudiant les décalages vers
le rouge des galaxies lointaines, il conclut
que l’univers était en expansion.
Mieux, en remontant le temps, et en combinant
des arguments de la mécanique quantique,
de la thermodynamique et de la relativité
générale, Lemaître suggéra que l’univers
tout entier était issu d’un petit quantum
d’énergie.
Au passage, Lemaître redécouvrit les solutions
cosmologiques de Friedmann.
Cependant, cette fois, Lemaître argua que
ces solutions s’appliquaient à notre propre
univers.
La compréhension que Lemaître avait de la
physique était incroyable ! On dit parfois
que les convictions religieuses de Lemaître
l’ont aidé à suggérer ce qu’Einstein
niait.
Je ne sais pas trop quoi en penser.
Les mathématiques de Lemaître étaient vraiment
solide.
Néanmoins, sans doute la faute à leurs croyances
philosophiques, les physiciens contemporains
de Lemaître rejetèrent les idées de Lemaître
en bloque.
Off.
Toutefois, petit à petit, les idées de Lemaître
gagnèrent en popularité.
Einstein en vint même à enfin reconnaître
qu’il n’aurait pas dû rajouter une constante
cosmologique, juste pour que sa théorie s’accorde
avec ses croyances philosophiques.
Il reconnut qu’ajouter cette constante cosmologique
était la plus grosse bêtise de sa vie.
Mais…
était-ce une bêtise ? D’un côté, on
peut juste voir ça comme une façon d’aligner
la théorie avec le consensus de la communauté
scientifique quant à la destinée de l’univers.
D’un autre côté, on peut aussi voir la
bêtise d’Einstein comme une caractérisation
de l’ensemble des équations raisonnables
de la relativité générale.
Très rapidement, ce que j’entends par là,
c’est que les combinaisons linéaires du
tenseur d’Einstein et du tenseur métrique
sont les seuls tenseurs de valence 2 faits
de dérivées au plus secondes du tenseur
métrique à être de quadri-divergence nulle.
Et je vous promets que c’est un théorème
mathématique vraiment joli !
Quoiqu’il en soit, c’est parce que l’équation
modifiée d’Einstein reste très raisonnable
que les physiciens se sont précipités dessus,
suite à des découvertes observationnelles
récentes…
Off.
En 1998, suite à des analyses de décalage
vers le rouge de galaxies très lointaines,
des physiciens ont découvert que, non seulement
l’univers est en expansion, mais cette expansion
de l’univers est en train de s’accélérer.
Dans un futur très lointain, l’expansion
de l’univers sera si rapide que toutes les
autres galaxies s’éloigneront de nous à
une vitesse supérieure à celle de la lumière,
si bien que nos descendants auront l’impression
d’être seuls dans une galaxie unique dans
l’univers.
Plutôt que vers un Big Crunch ou Big Chill,
l’univers semble voué à mourir en Big
Rip, dans un futur où les galaxies, les systèmes
solaires, les planètes, et même les atomes
finiront par s’isoler spatialement.
Voilà qui est clairement inconsistent avec
l’équation originale d’Einstein, qui
suggère que l’expansion de l’univers
devrait au moins ralentir.
Comme je l’ai dit dans une vidéo précédente,
ceci est une anomalie qui contredit l’équation
originale d’Einstein de la relativité générale.
Cependant, aussi étrange que cela puisse
paraître, ceci est aussi étonnamment consistant
avec l’équation modifiée d’Einstein,
celle dont il disait qu’elle était sa plus
grosse bêtise.
Off.
Les physiciens ont depuis donné un nom à
la cause de l’expansion accélérée de
l’univers.
Ils l’appellent l’énergie sombre ou énergie
noire.
Mais il ne s’agit là que d’un nom pour
faire référence à quelque chose que l’on
ne comprend absolument pas de manière fondamentale.
En fait, la nature de l’énergie sombre
est l’un des plus grands mystères de la
physique moderne, et des tentatives de l’expliquer
via la physique quantique ont échoué lamentablement.
David sur Science Étonnante appelle même
ces tentatives “la plus grosse erreur de
l’Histoire de la physique”.
Off.
Ironiquement, l’explication la plus avancée
aujourd’hui est celle donnée par Einstein
et sa constante cosmologique, un demi-siècle
après qu’il l’a honteusement retirée,
quelques décennies l’avoir honteusement
ajoutée.
Étrangement, les physiciens d’aujourd’hui
affirment que la plus grosse bêtise d’Einstein
n’était en
fait
pas
une bêtise…